everybody thank you so much for joining
us today welcome to the r studio
enterprise community meetup
i'm rachel dempsey i'm calling in from
boston today
as you can see
we're doing things a little bit
different from normal meetups today and
are streaming out to linkedin facebook
youtube and twitter
a huge thank you to tom mock who's
hanging out and helping behind the
scenes as well
i'm also joined by my colleague today
phil bauscher
hey everybody thanks for coming i'm phil
bauscher the director of life sciences
and healthcare here at our studio
if you just joined now feel free to also
introduce yourselves through the chat
window of wherever you're
watching from and say hello
maybe where you're calling in from
but for anybody who's joining this group
for the first time this is a friendly
and open meetup environment for teams to
share the work they're doing within
their organizations teach lessons
learned network with each other and
really just allow us all to learn from
each other
so thank you all for always making this
such a welcoming community
we really want to create spaces where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from everyone so i like to
reiterate that we love to hear from
everyone no matter your level of
experience
or industry that you work in as well
while you can ask questions on whichever
platform you're watching from
you can also question ask questions
anonymously as well
through the slido that we have which
i'll put up right here on the screen
but we are so excited to have so many
members of the pharma community here
today as well so i'd love to use this
opportunity to also share some
information
about a few other pharma communities and
hand it over to phil bauscher from our
team who is the best resource for all of
that
awesome thank you rachel very excited to
be here today
so this is the sixth installment of our
life sciences series
previously we've highlighted webinars by
gsk by novaris roche and genentech by
johnson johnson and even the epa
and you can find these webinars on our
life sciences champion page which rachel
is going to highlight now
on the screen
over the last seven years at our studio
my team and i have helped
many many organizations use r for
submissions especially
in the pkpd space and i would say in the
last two to three years there's been a
lot of interest to use r for late stage
clinical trials and many of the
organizations that we work with you know
they have different approaches to
validation to qualification for risk for
reporting and you can find some of our
supporting documents that we have on our
pharma page that rachel is showing here
at the r and pharma gathering that
happens every year
you can see many of talks from the past
conferences that highlight different
approaches to submissions and how
organizations are handling some of these
things
the also i'll i'll point out that the rn
pharma conference is coming up it's a
free virtual conference will be in
november and we hope to highlight both
how small and large organizations are
approaching
clinical submissions using r
and today we're going to be featuring uh
one way that an organization has
approached this which is through merck
and um and this is really going to
highlight the awesome work from nan zhao
yi long our speaker kevin anderson uh
sarah wang uh samya yee and countless
countless other
people at merck that have helped to
enable the r reporting as well as
documenting it for the community it's
just really fantastic
um and you know one one example of this
which is very exciting is the use of the
r package gs design
um kevin anderson leads up that was used
for the um moderna vaccine
and so
at lauren pharma last year this webinar
that we're featuring for you today uh
was one of the most
highly attended booked up webinars or or
workshops that we had and it's so
exciting that we get to bring this for
the community today and bring it to a
larger audience and highlight this
fantastic work uh from merck and so it's
with a great pleasure that i'll pass it
over now
to yeelong to highlight and talk about
this work that they're doing
and i'll just also say as mentioned
earlier we will have time for q a as
well so you can put your questions into
wherever you're watching from or use the
slido link which i'll pull up once again
right here
but i'm so excited to be joined by yilan
zhang now from the health technology
research team at meta to talk about his
experience at merck where he focused on
developing clinical workflows and
clinical reporting and has been an
amazing addition to the community
so with all of that thank you all again
for joining us it's amazing to see such
a great group of people here and i would
love to turn it over to you yulong
and we will go backstage i'll bring you
on here
yeah thank you rachel for the step i'm
thank you for feel for the greater
introductory yeah today
i'd like to share over experience of
using r for clinical study report and
submission and this is a work where i'm
at work to work with a group of talented
members within and of course a farmer
to share how we are thinking of the
recommendation and experience for late
stage clinical trial to submit the work
to the fda or for the other regulatory
agencies show the so-called eced package
to their portal
and
before it starts just a general
disclaimer so all opinion express here
just for my own and doesn't represent
any organization
and some of the slides here once you get
the link you probably can scroll down to
save some full content
so
uh before we start i think it's just to
reinforce the clarification from the fda
right from the fda's statistical
software clarification statement it's
clear to see that fda doesn't require
use of any specific software for the
statistical analysis for clinical trials
but there's definitely a requirement to
fulfill the 21 cfr project 11 to
complete the qualification software and
also to conduct analysis in a gxp manner
so for here it's more like we show how
we are thinking
to execute following this clarification
statement to meet the requirement from
regulatory agency to complete the
analysis and also to generate a report
that's ready for the submission
so with regard to the motivation why one
need to use r or different up package
for regulatory development right so for
this stage it's also have many of the
space that all have a lot of the
nice package to be used for the clinical
trial development for example r has been
widely used for cleaner choice study
design for example for group sequential
design and phil mentioned the gst
package for group sequential design has
been widely used within work or beyond
and also recently the development of
non-propulsion has group sequential
designs also under development in odd
and handy and probably available and
last year kevin just gave a nice
seminar to the gaming conference to go
through the information and if you're
interested you can go to this book down
project to see
all the information
and secondly so recently you can see a
trend of using
estimate framework following the ichen
ir1 addendum
so in response that noble missing data
approach may need to be applied for
example in recent paper we collaborate
with academia members for recurrent
event data and robustness submission
data but all this method has been
implemented in as an our package and
public available so when
a click trial try to apply those noble
methods to their trial instead of you
re-including other software maybe we can
just apply those are packaged available
to the clinical trial study with a
proper manner that package has been
qualified and tested before it can be
used for the final results
and you as you may aware i also like to
use for visual statistics with a popular
package like stan right to be able to
handle the vision modeling for
hierarchical modeling and sometimes for
the network meta-analysis in hd space
the drug reimbursement analysis can also
be applied in this framework
so in addition i always have strengths
for the virtualization part right so
there are some
dedicated work related to the pharma for
example the safety graphics working
group has created a nice shiny app to
summarize a bunch of quite commonly used
safety graph
and also another example like we're
exploring how we can use an interactive
focus plot to help simplify the dmc
safety monitoring review right so if
you're interested there's a recent uh
talk by our colleague uh each year at
the iem pharma conference to highlight
how this uh small package firstly can be
used to create an interactive force plot
to
aggregate the safety information and to
have a quick review and digest by the
dmc member
so these are some motivations that drive
us to explore more of a proper and
compliant way of using r for regulatory
submission
so for some background uh the work here
was still trying to follow the ich
guidance right for the clinical study
report while following ich e3 to
structure the content of a clinical
study report and for the
com company book alpha csr.org
contain all the
detailed information step by step how we
can create some example uh tables using
the tool we provided and also we're
trying to fill the gap to streamline the
workflow right so in the same book we
try to discuss lots of
concept for project management including
a tri-study
space and provide some recommendations
for that and in the end the most
important part once we complete analysis
in r we need to find a way to properly
submit the results and source code and
data
to the regulatory agencies through the
format required by the regulatory agency
that's basically this ectd format
required by most of the
global submission
situation for drug development
and for the table list and figures for
this talk overfocused here to deliver
the results in rtf or microsoft word
format because in most of the pharma
company the rtf for microsoft word still
play a central role to combine all the
table listing figures into the clinical
study reports so to collaborate with
conditions and with the medical writing
and the regulatory group right so people
still using the microsoft word as a like
a key component to combine all these
things together so that's how we play
the focus on the
microsoft word workflow right and also
acknowledge that different organizations
can have different ways to complete
their study report and the table
standard can be different so this is
just one recommendation how
we at work is handling those framework
and
so
for part that we work open space is
about our consortium pilot submission
right so our consortium frame a nice
working group
to organize people from both the
regulatory
agency and the thermal companies in
different representatives to get
everyone set together and also to think
how we can submit the what company you
are to the fda so with this nice working
group so we contribute together totally
in open space area so you can go to the
link like to identify whose member and
affiliations and for now what i'm trying
to share is outstanding work by this
working group for the first pilot that
we are able to prepare the analysis
package and prepare into the ectd format
and then sub into fda with review and
here's just a short timeline right so
about november last year so we initiated
this submission uh to fda and then
receive the fda response in december so
in the response we receive some feedback
and comments so we try to address them
and submit a revised submission to the
fda
and in march this year we received the
final fda response and all those
submission and response letters are
available on our consortium github
website that we will also have link in
following slides so
interested in the detail how the package
was organized and how the response
communication between the working group
and fda so all the information available
on github website so you can review and
explore so while we are dealing with
this first pilot submission so few
challenges that we need to solve the
first one is that every organization
will develop some internal
package for example to streamline the
workflow to wrap wrap up some open
source package available to a way that
easy to create the table figure layout
following the internal standard so so
you always
need to have some internal code that
need to be shared with regulatory agency
so one question is how we can submit
those internal developer appropriate
package to the fda right because in the
ectd format there are some
restrictions that you submit for example
we are not allowed to submit delete file
within the ectd package
and all the file names should be lower
cases without any special character
right and all content should be in
xbasic 2 format
so how we're going to deal with this
with a simplified way so that's the
first challenge we try to resolve and
basically a simple solution is to use a
package called peculite we will briefly
introduce uh in following slides
and the second part is how we can follow
the essay ics or fda guidance in
preparing the ectd package right ectd
have multiple modules and typically
we're following uh our contents con
in the module 5 that's basically the
data set and the program
for a clinical study report
and for the data part typically we still
follow in the standard requirement to
use xpt format and r also have a package
to create those data
but for the first pilot we try to focus
on the analysis part by assuming all
those xpt data set is already available
how we're able to submit the analysis
program to the regulatory agency right
and the last part even though fda didn't
expect all the code is executed
executable or reproducible from fda
review perspective we still try to think
how we can enhance the reproducibility
from fda reverse perspective right how
they can rerun all the analysis code we
provide it uh in the ectd package in
easier manner right so what kind of step
by step instruction we need to provide
into the analysis data with your guide
so those are the challenge we are trying
to resolve in the first pilot summation
with some simple analysis
and just highlight again that the
assumption here still about the analysis
and the reporting part for the first
pilot will not yet to touch the atom
dataset or sdtm dataset generation to
support analysis yet but that can
potentially be some future
work for future pilotwork
so once we complete the first pilot
there are a few deliverables we com
combined into the ectd submission
package so the first one we're able to
create a
sudo
proprietary package i call sudo because
it's also available on github so you can
check what the package looks like
and also we provide our scripts for the
analysis that's also on github wrapper
and then
as part of the ectd package we also need
to provide an analysis data review guide
to detail like for example what's a
version of our and our package and
what's a step-by-step instruction to
rerun the code and also where to find
the
data set and output into the ectd
package so all those information will
become
be saved into a reveal guide and also be
available on the ectd package
so in reproduce the work there are two
open source uh data grapple so the first
one is more from development perspective
like as an organization
we need a space to save all the source
code documentation right so that's all
saved in this developer to represent as
an organization how we can organize all
those information together and the
current recommendation for the first
pilot is using our package for the
structure to organize all the
information as needed and those details
also be discussed in the offer csr book
and the second part once an organization
complete the development
then we need to reorder the information
for the necessary part to be
put into the ectd package into the
module 5 of the submission package
specifically so in that part
this is a second weapon called ectd
package wrapper that basically comes
with only the ectd part that's required
to be submitted through the fda portal
to the agency right
and once we complete the ectd submission
so our consortium provides a nice
announcement to summarize the
achievement of this work and probably
here also from the linking or from other
channel to see how this announcement
happens right so we're also providing
here just in case you want to check the
details
and after
we submit
the ectd package the initial one to the
fda so this is some highlight of the
response from the fda so first uh fda
reviewer confirmed that by using the r
version 4.1.1 fda was able to run the
submedia code and confirm the applicant
table and the summit figure in report
here at basically the pdf file combined
table is a reproducible
and also fda we will develop their own
code to crosstrack the results right so
the analysis was able to independently
generate all those tables using the
submit data
and there are also some minor comments
uh being identified by fda reviewer that
we basically try to address in the
second revised submission and if you are
interested in those minor comments or
suggestions
you can take a look at the initial
submission fda response that the four
fda letters to document the details
and for the revised submission we
basically to address those comments
identified in the first submission and
once we receive a response basically if
they agree that the initial phase of
this first pilot submission has been
completed and if you are interested on
the revised one you can also go to the
second link here to see the results
and once we complete the first pilot the
working group team members started
wisdom what can we provide more to the
community what would be over future work
for the second or potential third pilot
submission
so there are few things being identified
and team members are working on those
efforts for example we want to see if
it's possible to submit a shiny app
within the ectd package to the fda so
the fda reviewer can rerun the shiny app
in their local machine and to start to
explore and digest information more
efficiently in an interactive way right
and second part so the first pilot only
targeted on fda
for an organization typically we are
thinking about global submission for
drug development right so we also try to
identify the potential point of contact
for different regulatory agencies for
example in eu in china or japan and see
if we can also start first pilot to
those regulatory agencies and hear
feedback to continue improve the
workflow to potentially prepare a full
submission using r for global regulatory
submission
and in addition for the first submission
the analysis is quite simple and uh like
simply the baseline crack rest table
some a summary table or a simple and
clover analysis for efficacy right there
could be more advanced analysis require
some complicated package with certain
system dependency right so we'd like to
also explore the possibility of the
submission with some advanced energy
method for example for study design or
for missing data and foundation method
as we discussed in the motivation of
this work
so once we discuss some high level
information about the fda pilot
submission
so i would like to go a little bit deep
on
how we are thinking about
reproducibility
and also based on guidance from fda some
recommendations we can take from the
pilot submission
so these diagrams borrow from roger
pone's famous science paper in 2011 to
discuss reproducibility in general right
so this diagram basically shows the
concept between the four replications
which represent we can fully represent
the data set and analysis right which is
unlikely to happen in clean trial space
because
how expensive a clean trial could be
right so most likely overreproducibility
is more referring to the code part right
with a given data set generated from
working with file
so how we can reproduce the analysis
from the data set so that's basically
the part from the code site
and within the code site there's also
multiple levels about the
reproducibility
so for the first part right so if we
have some internal developer package
then we need to version it and we need
to reproduce with a certain version
right and second part there is also open
space our version of package version
need to be managed so ensure
reproducibility and in addition
sometimes you may see some discrepancy
for the results between operation system
this is also true for many other
software right so the assumption is that
within a operation system then we
reproduce results i think that's also
the concept like why we need a contender
for many of the
analysis to ensure reproducibility right
and
one more
even more chinese situation that in very
rare cases you may get some trouble with
different hardware even though you are
running the same operating system
or you are along the same r and r
package version i would say this part is
really unlikely to happen but i just
want to highlight this user also the
part of need to be considered if we're
doing something seriously
but for now
over reproducibility is only focused on
the first two parts you know about r
version and about our package version
within a predefined operation system and
hardware
right so in that case this is how
we are discussing the reproducibility
and with this given definition so we
start to review the requirement from fda
like how fda was thinking about the
reproducibility of the code
so from fda study data technical
confirms guide we would just quote this
paragraph
basically
from the sponsor perspective
we need to provide a software program we
need to provide the adam dataset used to
generate the table and figure social
with the primary and secondary efficacy
analysis in other words
the city
analysis code typically considered as
optional
right so the focus from fda perspective
is to run the source code for primary
and secondary efficacy analysis
and the second part
the specific software utilized should be
specified in the analysis data with your
guide like which are version which are
packaged version need to be documented
properly to ensure reproducibility
and also
fda try to highlight that is to
understand the process by which the
variable for the respective analysis was
were created and to confirm the analysis
algorithm
basically over understanding is that f
fda
i see some
background
did i say recording
it still sounds good to me
i can
okay yeah i just get my own
voice
okay probably let's continue
so
in that case of understanding that
so fda didn't expect the code can
generally be executable
from your end
and the goal to have those software
program
is to understand which variable in the
atom data set
has been used for the analysis and which
exact app and us acronym for example
for ancova model virtual model terms
what's your missing data strategy to
handle them in the code space right
because that's exactly what you do
in the analysis
and also at the expect
the software program should be in
ask to the text format in other words
those azure crafter shouldn't be put in
the source code
so to achieve that
here's some recommendations from over
end
so first when we are doing the final
analysis
for the clinic study report we need to
fix the r version
for example r421.10
and also when you fix a snapshot date
for example
uh august 31st 2021 the purpose to have
a snapshot thing
is to fix the ipad version
we are using for the analysis
and this is both achievable by the
australian public package manager
and also for the current time machine
created by the mrn or if within your
organization you have a commercial
version of azure patch manager you can
have a time motion to
both froze the internal and the external
developed r package
right
so this is how a snapshot date can be
helpful
to pre-specify
the operating version in the final
analysis you still need to specify each
version of the operating used for your
analysis
and also
we need to consider flexibility of input
output pass because we call send to the
fd review part
the source code tabs for the data set
will be different
so some guidance
to update the path of the input output
should be provided in ns review data
guide
and also
lots of parts should be clarified into
the ideology
and basically understanding typical fda
reviewer is doing the analysis
in the windows mission
and for some
organization maybe we complete our
analysis in a different operation system
example linux server
so in that case
uh we want to rerun the ectd package and
the driver will overwhelm this merchant
as well
to ensure it's fully reproducible from
the sponsor end before we do the
submission
right and all those steps can be
detailed in the adidas appendix and in
the first pilot we provide an example of
step-by-step instruction in that case
so here we go to a little more detail
about the implementation part how this
was handled
so in general
we share the same philosophy
as a heavily implemented package right
so we just quote here so anything can be
automatic should automatic so we want to
do as
little as possible by hand we want to do
as much as possible with functions
that's why we're trying to create our
package to simplify the workflow
and also a goal is for over developers
to see more of what needs to be
deliverable instead of to worry about
what our packaging looks like right so
we only bundle them together and be
available in open space
and here are a few tools we developed to
simplify that
so the first part
is how we can generate the production
ready table and figures rtf format so
that's how we create a package called
r2rtf to achieve that
and the second part is mention how to
get all those internal package available
into the
ectd package so request patent contact
you like to represent our package into
the pure txt format
and also can
we
revert and also install back into the
reverse mission and the last piece the
under internal validation is how we can
create a portfolio environment
to help the reviewer also have the dry
run to complete analysis because on your
machine you can have different
operations you might pack into your user
space right what if the submission
package of different r and r patent
version right you want to have a self
content folder
to reproduce that once you complete that
you can just delete
and that doesn't have impact for your
system
and all the details is available in our
csr book so if you are interested you
can go there to find the detail for now
i just give some highlight
so for the first lines about archwagia
it contains several functions
to pipe together to generate an rtf
format
so let's basically assume the data set
is already available for example you can
handle that entivers or other package
once the data says available architects
will format it into the rtf
default
the production
it's also the
other app is available to do the same
work for example create our package r
table to do a simple executable format
and authorized have a particular pharma
rtf
to also create tables in rtf all right
and there's also other general tools
like gt
or x table and
other two available so right so for here
it's just for operation try to use this
package to generate the files but it's
not necessary to be the only solution
and the second part is about to combine
all the internal r package together into
one txt file
that be able to save into the ectd
package module 5.
so patch light is a tool to pack all
package into the plain text
it's also grammar to specify which part
of your internal package needs to be
packed for example you don't have to
pass your testing code you don't have to
pass all the video of a r package
to your part because the goal is to have
the source code in the offloader to be
executable from a reviewer part
right
also it creates a standard
the test file can just be open and be
revealed so
you can still take a look what has been
assembled
into the final submission package
right so this is just an example code
once you provide the path to the package
you can collate then we have a
convenient function to indicate what
typically we consider to be saving an
ectp heritage right and sometimes you
want to specify more for example you
have some additional material in ist
folder
you can also pack multiple rfid
into one file so you have two
package internally developed and saved
into one txt file
and once the txt file is available
people can just unpack in their local
machine and you can also specify install
equal to two that automatically install
into your system
and the last piece
is about the portfolio environment right
so
to rerun the analysis you probably need
your
approach file specified studio
configuration a dot our profile or
doctor environment for that right
so to recreate the wrong environment
and that's also been enabling nicely in
addition
we can install specific version for
example r4.1.1 to a project folder we
can specify there are tools because some
of our packages need to be compiled you
still need our tools in that part
so all those information can be covered
in your clean slate in this pipeline and
you can specify what information you
need in this portable environment
once the setup it can be used for the
drywall or for the fda reviewer to
review content to simplify multiple
steps
in the ideology
okay
so as a summary
uh i will try to say as a newer story
right so for extradition
we can use type inverse rtrtf or other
internal tool to define the multiple
to
create a listing and figures for the
special analysis of your trial because
typically you have have more than 100
tables figure for every sensitivity for
drug or vaccine development right so you
also need a way to organize them
efficiently
as a programmer we also use tight
reverse or arch ids another internal
tool to develop or validate analysis
results based on those work table
and as so our programmer
we also need to use patching light and
also as an internal tool to prepare
those internal develop package in a way
that can be saved into ectd
establishment package
and in the end
so as an internal external reviewer
we use clean slate to reconstruct the
particle environment
to reproduce energy results
we try also to give recommendation
details in our csr book
so for the food structure
part
when you have
more than 100 deliverables
how you organize that so over suggestion
is to use a
package folder structure
to ensure the consistency the
reproducibility automation components
because there's already a lot of tools
around our package that allow you to do
the analysis and do some complex check
so it's just one way we're thinking our
package structure can potentially be
used to organize all those things
together
and also for project management so we
also recommend people to sing a driveway
so set up for success and work as a team
because you always have much of
functional algorithm to work together
for your trial
we're also interesting to design clean
code structure where to make sure you
have proper documentation and relation
between the functions so other people
can understand when you change it from
project to another
and also it's necessary to set
capability boundaries right in that way
people can cross boundary to help but
also be clear the responsibility of each
row
and also importantly we would recommend
you to contribute to the community when
you feel like a tool that doesn't relate
to the business logic that can be
standalone package i would like to share
through the open space
in that way we can continue to grow and
to find the consensus to improve the
workflow across the farm
when we regard your software development
life cycle you should also follow
several steps like planning
developmentation operation part
so in each of the steps you need to be
properly handled for internal developer
package and also need to be handled to
qualify the external package right so
those information for example can be
referred a validation hard white paper
how organization can achieve that
and there are many courses in the
circumstances so the work here cannot be
achieved without all those outstanding
collaborations with people from across
pharma
so for example if your interest is to
understand how to qualify external
packing i would suggest go to our new
hub website and potentially the working
group and there are several
presentations being handled previously
to understand the workflow and tools
available
and for this talk we discuss the upper
establishment pilot
more future work
so what i'm welcome to
check the website i'm going to join and
contribute right and also i
found my conference just
wonderful
it helps us a lot organize together to
share the ideal information to
collaborate
and in addition arkansas adopting
seminars trying to share the information
including this meetup
so continue to share the knowledge
across different relationships it's
important to help to shape a better
solution towards the future
and for the future direction of the
current work we have so we still try to
enhance the compliance with the
disability because we have automation
right we want to also consider how we
can assemble the metadata around the
analysis
as you probably hear like the effort
from cd 360.
right
so we provide some prototype there's
some package called metallife from
metallic.led on the github merc website
so that way you can check how we are
thinking how metadata was flowed
from the planning and analysis reporting
in the clinical trial and nasa report
we also want to enable some advanced
study design special message and also
introduce some interactive
virtualization you know report freedom
for the
dmc
and also can be wazo without backhand
server
okay that's basically concluded all my
presentation today and thank you for
listening and
thank you so much ilong
you can't hear us clapping but we're all
clapping here let me pull phil back on
stage too
thank you so much for a great
presentation
i can see there's a lot of questions
coming in already so we'll do our best
to try and aggregate them from
everywhere
but i can see one question that has been
pinned to the chat
from minoge and apologies if i'm
pronouncing your name incorrectly um it
is would our replace sas completely
um or its usage to some extent
yeah we we don't think like uh
our work replaces us
yeah it's more like we add a
more
additional tool to the arsenal of the
clinical trial development
right
like within our organization definitely
we can have different tools even like
python junior potentially can be in the
development but we need a way to
consider what will be a compliant and
proper process for the development
thank you and and i just want to remind
people too that if you want to ask
questions anonymously as well you can
use the slido link that i just put up on
the screen
but otherwise we're gathering questions
from youtube facebook live stream and
twitter
but i see one question that's been
uploaded on slido
from kevin is
if not if you're not using containers is
rm playing a role in documenting
dependencies
yeah because
our pack yourself already have a
well-defined dependent structure in the
description file right
you can also use some nice package about
that i use to lock the file package
version as well right and that's also i
don't know why pack your light will also
be helpful because you just assemble all
the package within the txt file and you
can also unpack them so your r and r
package version has been fixed in your
site
so i would say a contender
is not necessary but will be a good ad
but one challenge from fda perspective
is how we can enable container
environment from fda perspective
awesome thank you i want to turn it over
to phil to
ask one of the questions that came
there's a lot of a lot of good ones
coming in but uh young one i thought you
could help with here is a question says
what's the difference between ectd
and sdtm formats is one preferred and
does your package only support one
okay so there are two different concepts
so sdtm is a data standard
so that's basically what the source data
should be organized
when you connect from the crf
and ectd is more like a
folder structure to organize a clinical
study report like all the files from
the clinical implementation operation
your clinical study report your data set
right so sdkm data set just one
component stay in the ectp package
thank you um
i see okay another upvoted question that
came in anonymously that i want to be
sure to ask is
i'm a grad student with limited r
experience interested in trials the
decision to make r my main software is a
big one
why would i want to make the switch
how sorry switch between what
um so i think
they're talking about their decision to
make our
their main tool
what are some of the reasons they may
want to make that switch
i'm trying
to understand so
definitely people have their own comfort
zone
they have their favorite tools for
development
but as an organization
they have their own process their
standard a group of people share the
same consensus how will competitors work
when people join organization i would
suggest to first follow
their existing process and consensus
and also to see if that match with your
own interest and your comfort belong
right
so i wouldn't say
people need to change to yourself or use
arm but i would think it's more like a
much in greater space it's better to
learn multiple language to learn and
borrow from the strengths of each
language
fantastic awesome i think i can uh i can
take the next one rachel here
um
so to kind of switch up some of the
topics a little bit someone says for
deep learning python is a popular choice
uh what efforts are made to address this
and are um elong has has your team at
edmer
tackled any of the deep learning space
for clinical
well i have very much experience on this
but for us
i know you have some outstanding tools
maybe you got better yeah yeah yeah
yeah so i can um i can attach some uh
some links to a workshop that we teach
but uh there's been a lot of updates in
this space
uh one is the fact that there's the
reticulate package which helps translate
r to python it helps the interoptability
between r and python
so that's a big piece of it
you can also just come to python
directly which is which is fantastic and
a lot of the ecosystem now supports that
um there's also the tensorflow package
that's been created for our jj alera our
founder gave a great keynote on this at
the 2018 uh our studio conference so
i'll put a i'll put a link into the chat
uh with some deep learning examples um
but uh yeah i don't see a ton of this in
clinical but i was just curious elon if
uh if it had come up for you so
i'm also gonna share a link to a meetup
that's coming up on june 1st on using
python in our studio team if it's of
interest to anyone too i'll i'll put it
in the in the chat
but i see there's a question that came
over from linkedin live
that says thank you yulong for the great
talk
have you and your team consider the use
of our markdown to integrate the report
writing with the analysis and reporting
yeah
the first pilot armada is used
for the reporting part
awesome
let me go back over to some of the
linkedin questions here too and one was
would fda accept submissions with r
despite the fact that r does not come
with any warranty
well so
i wouldn't say it's not congress
guarantee
it's more like
as an organization
you become a customer of an open source
software
because that's not like a close-up so
they have some pure statement
so often they should also have a pdf
file to clarify how r can be used
in the clinical trial development part
and for organization it becomes the
organization and custom also to maintain
documents to clarify as organization how
you are using open source software
following the gxp guidance once that's
been cleaned i think that's the patient
for
the analysis part
so as
clarify your
fda classification fda you can see that
you have to use some software that's
being developed by a company and all
closed source right
awesome thank you phil i'm going to turn
it over to you to ask the next
question all right let me see if i can
find one over here streaming in from
linkedin
all right
or i can ask one from slido if you
didn't find one
so i found one here that i thought it
was pretty cool it says how are formats
how are the formats handled in r
and i suspect that's a question on the
maybe the data formats for clinical
trials
um i know elon you're pretty active in
that space uh
what was that like for you tackling the
data management side
of these clinical workflows
yeah sure
is language independent
so
we definitely will follow the sdtm adam
data standard
and fda require data to design the xpg
format that's open source format user is
developed by sas
so in other words this is the same
workflow we need to achieve
no matter where using any software
language
thank
you
um so i'll go over to some of the
anonymous questions and one is what
steps did you take to validate the r
packages themselves
yeah i would just recommend one
pharmaceutical paper we developed last
year so we provide the clear guidance
like a step-by-step instruction so in
general it's a follow heavily recommends
our package book
right so we use a structure to go
through them but we need to pre-specify
the testing plan we also need some
independent testing and potentially
double programming for the code so like
atomization you definitely will need
some execution results to quantify and
develop internal package so this can
mimic the existing process to other
language you already have in
organization
i think i think i got one here rachel
that's pretty good um someone's asked
about how to approach
macros and r or similar things to macros
and r what's what has that been like for
you
um using r
yeah that's also question discuss a lot
while we start
so for now we're trying to see how to
provide end-to-end solution because the
way to mix multiple language can create
additional challenge from i.t
from your internal process but which
part of the process you want to give
yourself on
become unclear in your
process so for now we haven't go through
the detail how to hybridly
use
one particular analysis
but in a study where you have much more
believable right you can have some
variable in class some deliverable you
are that can be executed independently
i think i think one thing too the
question is trying to tackle is what
were similarities in the r
experience for you in putting together
the clinical trials to what others may
have experienced with with macros
was was that the functions that you
built was it the packages that you
designed
you know was it uh was it um did you
have different routines or workflows
that you shared within the team in r
that were reproducible and could be
packaged up and shared
yeah
my experience is that different
companies have different workflows you
know how to use that macro to generate
the results
and it's the same oh right probably if
you consider merge flow watch flow
that can be different right so in the
alpha csr we provide one recommendation
how to do the project management
and we imagine where to save each of the
files in the full structure within our
package
this is how we are thinking a way to
handle a large amount of table figure
listing required for analysis
thank you
oh sorry phil did you want to i was just
gonna
i was just going to ask a question that
i'm selfishly interested in just based
on some of the work that we're doing
with our informa is shiny did your team
look think about using shiny in the
submissions process
well this probably you can get more
answers from watch team
yeah so definitely i think the second
pilot as mentioned is about the shiny
app part i think the team is actually
working on that to explore how to use a
file with the uctd and potentially
produce
in the reveal
very cool thank you thank you
i see sylvia asked a great question i
think it was coming through
from linkedin
and it was thanks you long in your
experience are the external reviewers at
fda for r versus sas the same group
trying to think if there would be a
delay
caused in review since sas is more
popular for the past two decades
i wouldn't represent fda
my
general hearing when we have the working
group
so fda members have people familiar with
r or sas or either
and also in fbs guidance
it's also recommend you indicate a
software you use in the type c meeting
for pre-imd
submission so in that way fda can be
aware what kind of software you are
trying to use
sorry i froze for a second phil if you
can take the next question oh yeah yeah
yeah so i see um let me see what we have
here
the pages uh refreshing on me so i'm
trying to keep up with how fast it's
moving um
so one question that i saw was about
admiral i don't know where it went but i
think the question was you know people
are interested in using admiral for
prepping data sets for clinical trials
um you know um or here i just found it
said any other package for clinical
trials data set creation which is useful
if we lost
yeah i think but there is a wonderful
project another group of people are
trying to see how to
uh develop the atom dataset called in
the central place
right in general for most data
manipulation i would say tie diversity
sufficient
right so for your exploration or for
developer code
for the data set generation
i think see long
i see uh someone else asked on linkedin
is shiny meta
is the shiny meta package a better way
to build reproducibility for fda
ah i don't have exercise on that
so i can just provide some color so
shiny meta is a package that was created
by the shiny team in our studio probably
about two or three years ago and it
helps implement reproducibility within
workflows within shiny applications uh
so i would say um you know stay tuned or
watch some of the shiny first
submissions working group information on
the rn pharma website uh there's there's
a couple different approaches to
reproducibility via shiny and it will be
interesting to see uh you know what
becomes more of a standard as more shiny
apps are shipped off through the
submissions process but uh um i i do
think it's a great way for
reproducibility but it also takes a
little bit of learning so
it will be interesting to see if it's
adopted or if there's other preferred
approaches
awesome i just want to take a second to
address a few questions about where the
slides exist so i just put on the screen
right here the slides for today that
yulong had shared with us before the
event
and then also a few questions around the
recording so one of the great things
about using this live streaming
tool is that the recording will be there
immediately
on youtube
so i'll be sure to share that link there
as well
okay we go over to a few other questions
and thank you tom for helping organize
these for us and in the back end
okay this is a bit of a long question so
let me
take a second here um tanisha asks
what is
the expectation so oh sorry it
disappeared for a second okay all data
sets and display creation in sas and qc
in r
or vice versa
or only display creation in sas and qc
in r
and i think everybody can read the
question too but um or a total mix and
match of sas and r would be fine for fda
submission
yeah the voice have some lab if my
understanding could you are referring
something that's created in r or
validity in size or vice versa
so what's the question
can you see the question on the
screen too
okay
i think what they're getting at is will
submissions be
a mix and match of sas and r
um
because it yeah it's quite a big
question
maybe just comment about that elon what
the you know do you think organizations
will mix the two will
will organizations choose to use r will
they use r internally for the prep what
do you think
or what was this like for your team i
just feel some multi-linguistic way
right but for particular tasks
it's better to be consensus on the tool
to be used
right for example if
the goal is to create another sense for
survival it's better all the trial for
organization is used the same way
instead of you have multiple ways even
within sas
always in r you want to use only one r
package instead of multiple package to
do the same thing
thank you
there are quite a few other anonymous
questions so i want to make sure that i
get over to those as well and
just so everyone knows we'll be
collecting all the questions and make
sure that we answer these too
um so maybe in some blog post format as
well
but one of the questions
is around so it says are there any
security issues with using r
versus python
this person said my hospital i.t team is
less familiar with r and has questions
about how secure the packages are
phil would you want to address that
i mean i think uh the thing to to know
and i think is important is that cran uh
and our foundation does a wonderful job
of running checks when packages are
submitted
and um you know that that typically is a
pretty good thing to lean on and to
understand um and some organizations
have some scanning tools and things that
they use internally
but but that usually is enough for
people to understand
for what it takes to get a package to
cran which is not a
it's a big undertaking and it's a lot
and you know for package developers to
maintain and support and so that's a big
part of it
awesome i just put a
link on the screen right now that might
be helpful for the person who asked the
question to
so it's just our champion site
and there's a separate section on on
working with it too
phil do you see any other questions
you know i think i think we're after the
time i don't if we can keep going all
afternoon if that's okay but um um
you know i'm sure yulong's gotta get
back to
his his work but uh i i do see some more
maybe a blog post and aggregating and
collecting these up would be the right
way to approach it because you long
there's a lot of interest in this
there's a lot of questions coming in for
you too so
um cool
yeah rachel how far after did you want
to go today
well i don't want to take too much of
you long's time because thank you so
much for the awesome presentation too do
you have time for
a few more
yeah probably
more
okay
all right you pick one and i'll pick one
how about that rachel okay you go first
all right um
let me see here let me see what's coming
in
uh let me see let me see
so i think
the one
that is interesting here
would be um
so i see a lot of questions i think
about docker and containers
and using that infrastructure for some
of this work
um
you know i'm i'm interested
elon what uh what that was like has did
that was that part of the conversations
you know
what what would that look like maybe a
hypothetical world with the fda or other
regulatory bodies have you has your team
thought about that
yeah
personally i haven't tried darker i
basically have very limited experience
on that
and it's definitely a bring up
in many conversations for last time
mission working group
i think the one challenge still how to
get fda ready to receive the information
right from your own
organization i think dog could be a very
good way or contender solution right i
would think like eric entering a dog
from different teams they have better
understanding of potentially a live
stream about itself so that would be
nice
great thank you um
so one other question i'll go over to
the slido
there was anonymous question which i
know we've touched on reproducibility a
bit but
what's the best practice for a group of
programmers using r for submission
to avoid
any challenges with reproducibility
yeah sorry i could still hear the lack
of noise
sorry what's best what's the best
practice for a group of programmers
using r
to avoid any challenges with
reproducibility
well i think first thing start to use
version control
second
have your profile set properly and in a
shared space
that people can all access the same
location
so i think in general that would be some
good way to enhance reproducibility and
if you're familiar with ie or other
package try to use him to lock your
package version
awesome
well
with everybody here i do want to also
have take a just a second to let you
know that we do have
um another pharma meetup coming up in
august
and if tom can help me behind the scenes
i tried to prepare a caption for that to
pop up
but if you want to just see all future
events you can use the short link
we just put on the screen
r s t d dot io community dash events
but we will have a pharma meetup
specifically on august 23rd
left led by action at bristol-myers
squid
and ashton will be presenting on data as
a product so data science framework
for data collaborations
and i think that will be a great event
as well
i'll share in the chat just the add to
calendar link
if you want to
just add that right now
i'll put it right here
there you go
and i'll show that on the screen
so just
rstd.io
pharma
meetup and you can add that event to
your calendar too
but thank you so much elon for
sharing your time with us and your
experience
it's great to be able to learn from you
and and to see all these awesome
questions from the community too
phil i'll let you weigh in as well no
thank you it's always been uh exciting
to see the work that you do uh with your
team i always love following it and
watching it and yeah excited to see what
what you still produce
cool thank you
thanks yeah see ya have a great rest of
the day everybody